well the pandemic has taken a massive
toll on the restaurant industry
the nevada restaurant association
projecting 30 percent of the state's
restaurants will close by the end of the
year
but one local very popular spot working
to bounce back
thai restaurant lotus of siam has
reopened its newest location near
paradise and flamingo
a ribbon cutting ceremony was held
before dinner service tonight
the restaurant closed in march when
restrictions first came down
then the owners had to deal with repairs
from a water leak they say getting to
this
point was not easy but they are so happy
to be back open
we welcome everyone with open arms we're
here we take everybody's safety
seriously
you know for not just our employees but
our guests as well
you know just come here have a good time
and we thank you for everybody that's
been very patient with this location
the second and original location is also
near sahara and maryland parkway that
spot was closed for renovations until
may of this year
after a 2017 rainstorm caused a roof
collapse it is a great
restaurant